remember cowboy bebop well it's back in
live action form the legendary anime
which has reached mythical levels of
adoration has now been adapted into a
netflix show for better or worse
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down the show as a whole
talking about the changes and also
giving our thoughts on it because of
this there will be heavy spoilers so if
you haven't had a chance to check it out
then i highly recommend that you check
out now if you enjoy the video then
please hit the thumbs up button and also
make sure you subscribe for breakdowns
like this each and every day without the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into cowboy bebop okay so the
original anime notably ended on a
cliffhanger after less than 30 episodes
and whether we go beyond that point
remains to be seen however the series is
very much going to be a jumping off
point to start something new and because
of that there's a lot to talk about with
the ending the people behind the show
have said how they didn't want to make
it a shot for short remake to avoid
unflattering comparisons and due to this
the netflix series is wildly different
now i want to talk about the changes
first but if you want to skip ahead to
just the ending then time codes will be
linked below in the lead up to its
release lots of things were brought up
on its accuracy with many saying that
face should have been costumed to look a
lot more like her anime counterpart
there's a ton of changes in the series
and they also notably removed air up
until the very very last moment that
kind of teases a season 2 where the
original pretty much ended and as such
we might get some of the missing
plotlines used in the future such as the
titan war and ed's entire storyline now
the original had three lost souls trying
to find themselves amongst a time of
capitalist greed in which it was a very
doggy dog universe the series is very
much laced with the idea that modern
life is rubbish boring and futile unless
you've got an amazing youtube channel
you can watch every day now in the anime
this was explored particularly through
the marks that the crew hunted but here
they've been reduced to nothing more
than jokes for example in the original
the teddy bomber was an anarchist and
the joke was that his manifesto was
constantly being interrupted until he
finally explained it and realized how
futile it was here he's literally a giza
called ted who's nuts the manifesto is
laughed at he wears a teddy bear costume
and gets bested in about five minutes
there's lots of things like that that
sort of hamper the experience if you
love the original and honestly if you're
here before seeing the show i would
probably watch the live action one first
before tackling that now as for the
series and its ending it's been
massively changed up from the original
before we get into that though we kind
of need to talk about the big reveals in
episode 9 which fill us in on the
backstory of spike we always knew that
spike aka fearless worked for the
syndicate a savage and brutal criminal
cartel and we are drip fed with
knowledge throughout the show about his
former life we're introduced to vicious
a man who quite literally lives up to
his name and we discover that he's the
son of the syndicate leader who's played
by john noble this was an awesome
unmasking and throughout the series we
see that vicious has no problem killing
his father and potentially even the
woman that he loves after the events of
episode 1 he learns that spike is still
alive and his side hustle of dealing
redeye is exposed which is something
that brings him into conflict with the
elders of the syndicate and nurse he
decides to take their more loud angle
for the throne now in episode 9 we learn
exactly what happened between vicious
and spike and discovered that they were
pretty much adopted brothers with
fearless being brought in off the
streets they were very much yin and yang
with them having different methods and
ideologies for how to carry out their
hits and also their lives vicious is
just an idiot who doesn't care for the
repercussions of his actions and due to
the way his father treated him he's
clearly insecure and always wanting to
prove himself fearless on the other hand
is possibly the best worker the
syndicate have with him being smart
capable and cool under pressure he had a
fierce loyalty towards vicious and would
regularly clean up any mess that he made
we even see how vicious kills a guy and
wants to shoot a kitten woman but
fearless says no showing that whilst he
has grown up in this life he isn't a
sick sadistic person and just wants to
exist this explains why he also wants to
turn away from ruling the syndicate
which we'll talk about later on in the
video now the pair end up falling in
love with a woman named julia who
becomes integral to the ending and after
their boss capo orders spike to take
vicious out he has to make a tough
decision in the anime it was actually
mao who took the pair under their wing
whereas the person here is just another
capo like vicious this is because
vicious gets in over his head with a
neptune gang and felis has to come in
and clean up the mess once more fearless
tries to clear passage for him and julie
to escape and she's completely terrified
of the villain
in the anime vicious is dating julia but
she nurses spike back to health after he
was seriously injured he would later ask
her to leave the syndicate except
vicious found out about the affair and
ordered her to kill him while spike
waited for her at a graveyard she didn't
do this and instead it led to spike
being ambushed which then led into him
meeting jet i think that works way
better than what we get in the show and
we see spike is sent to kill vicious
after his major mess up with the neptune
gang in the live-action version it takes
the father of vicious to tell him what
the hell is going on and this leads into
him taking julia and then attempting to
kill spike to me in the live-action
version the character of vicious is
nothing more than a spoiled cry baby
brat throughout the entire show the
anime had the quote-unquote brothers on
equal pegging and for me the added
screen time did him no favors as in the
original he's in 5 out of the 26
episodes making him a much more
mysterious villain because of that
vicious in the anime left us wanting
more or as here he's in so much that it
kind of just gets annoying for me the
best part of the anime was seeing the
crazy wills and eclectic bounties which
we do get but the order of these
bounties has been changed heavily the
first bounty we see jet and spike vibe
for is similar to the first episode of
the anime but that's where most of the
similarities end as in episode 2 we move
to the teddy bomber and are missing
cowboy andy it's clear major subplots
are being saved for another season if
there is one as netflix loves to cancel
shows quicker than kevin's spoilers when
he does a thanos was right joke on
twitter unfortunately each bounty is
reduced to simply a device to push our
cast to where they need to be for the
story to progress instead of allowing
our main crew to breathe i think the
focus on vicious sort of takes attention
away from what made this show great that
was three people out on the edge of
society finding each other upon the
backdrop of nihilism jeff perfectly
exemplifies this as we learned that
before he met spike that he had the
ideal life with a wife and child in
episode 5 we discover how he was accused
of being a dirty cop but he would later
learn that it was actually his old
partner who had blamed him jett would
subsequently shoot him and sadly
chalmers the man banging his ex-wife
explained to him how because of this
there was no chance that he could clear
his name to me this story is definitely
the harshest as jett is a man who never
did anything wrong but he cements that
in this universe doing the right thing
can end your plans of a perfect life i
like the change here but the constant
checking in on this plot to make sure we
still remember it was annoying when i
just wanted to see the crew gone
bounties due to the expansion of vicious
story there's almost no room to explore
these cool facets or really the
relationship between our bebop crew now
the other mystery hanging over the show
is the backstory of fey which i'll be
talking about now so if you don't want
to know then skip ahead to the next
chapter in the video three two you still
here on you well now in the anime we
learn that she was born on earth in 1994
and during a trip to space in 2014 an
accident occurred that killed her
parents and it severely injured her a
video of her was time capsuleed which is
something that's brought to the show
though remains more of a dangling thread
she was then cryogenically frozen until
she was able to be healed but in doing
this she completely lost everything she
fell in love with a lawyer who brought
her up to speed with the universe but it
turned out he was just cunning her in
order to lumber her with lots of debt it
really highlighted the cold and cruel
world of bebop where they have this
amazing technology but everyone still
has to deal with issues like money and
being screwed over which turns her very
bitter instead the show goes with a
woman who pretended to be her mother
because of this we don't really get a
story about love and betrayal we get
jokes about akuga being chased by her
lover which yeah feels slightly lacking
in the series fei expects to find her
identity but she simply gets a vhs tape
of her as a young kid it's far and away
the least developed subplot that's
seemingly being saved for season 2 but i
do kind of wish that we'd explored it
more in this entry she heads off at the
end of the series to find out where the
video time capsule came from which will
not come back should we get another
entry either way each storyline leads up
to the end with vicious taking down the
elders and also his father vicious then
kidnaps jet's daughter kimmy and thus he
and spike track them down during which
julia is pulled into the mix we then see
our lads jettenced by captured with
vicious wanting to punish jet by also
killing kimmy spike says how he was
supposed to end vicious which is a
callback to his mercy being his undoing
once more but faye saves the day in the
final action scene spike is left to head
back into the church and we get a
showdown between him and vicious which
comes with one hell of a twist now julia
is way different to her anime
counterpart and originally she would
have rather lived a life on the run than
ever have had to kill spike here after
vicious is defeated julia is power
hungry and wants the syndicate for
herself she begrudges spike leaving her
and has been left bitter and twisted by
staying with vicious it's an odd change
and it alters spike's entire future as
he spent his cowboy years longing for
her but now his motivation is gone
throughout the series he never felt like
his nihilistic anime version but this
could be the final trauma that turns him
into the easy breezy cowboy as she
shoots him and he falls into a river
which of course mirrors his apparent
death at the hands of vicious it all
plays his chapter ends in a sort of buck
on his life and him rising from the
water very much signals his rebirth she
leaves him and because no one is able to
see vicious face as an elder she can
assume his identity and rule the
organization julia plays russian
roulette with him which of course calls
back to earlier in the season in which
he didn't know whether he would be
shooting her or not the bebop crew part
ways as jets hopes of finally being a
family man again are completely gone he
promises to kill spike if he ever sees
him again but as we know they'll
probably be back to being best buds at
some point spy keeping his original life
a secret from jet was a mistake as the
pair part ways and we closed out with ed
coming into the story ed was teased in
the london's ark in episode six by the
man who jet finds when they're hunting
him he mentions how he created an ai
which was londis and the man was sent
there by radical ed aka ed ed was a
major mystery in the anime and she was a
computer hacker who later joined the
bebop crew whilst they investigated
someone vandalizing earth here ed has
been tracking down spikes seemingly for
quite a while and wants to be a cowboy
and mentions many different bounties
such as valadium i kind of think that ed
will lead the team to get back together
as jet had a great father figure style
relationship with her which could now be
brought into the show as he'll probably
not see kimmy for a long time no doubt
the crew will get back together and i
think that if there is another season
that we will get the truth about faye
revealed they could somewhat integrate a
love story in which he's betrayed and
this would no doubt push her back into
rejoining the bebop they'll all kind of
have this feeling of betrayal right now
as julia of course betrayed spike and
spike lied to jet spike is the only one
who can make things right with him so i
think that will be a big help and
coupled with air they could make
somewhat of a dysfunctional family the
titan war was also name dropped a few
times and while vicious was in this war
in the anime i would expect to have this
flashed out more as well as what
happened with earth also julia is very
much a wild card and in the original
anime she was actually killed at the end
i think that they've set this up for
season two so that we have spike very
much having to take down the love of his
life this season was very much about him
taking down the person he once saw as a
brother and with her now leading the
syndicate he'll now have to take down
the person he loved it's about to take
to change the anime like they did and i
admit i am biased having watched it when
it was shown in the uk way back when and
again recently however both series end
with spike collapsing and we're unsure
whether he's dead or not in the original
whereas here ed kind of changes things
up a bit in the anime he was never
confirmed whether spike died or not but
there were several visual clues such as
doves flying overhead which were also
present when julia died either way
there's a lot we could get next time but
whether the show gets a second season or
not remains to be seen netflix have been
pretty brutal when it comes to
cancelling things and i'm not sure how
well received this will be though it's
not a complete travesty i do think it
shows that the west should try and steer
clear of adapting animes as it goes
wrong more times than it goes right
cowboy bebop i feel is a weird one to
review as there are some absolutely
brilliant parts but at the moment i'll
let it down it almost feels too much
like it's trying to be an anime at
points which for me doesn't really work
that well in live action add to it the
fact that they leave all the backstory
stuff until episode 9. i feel like most
of the season is a bit of a miss i would
love to have these origin aspects laced
throughout the runtime in flashbacks but
unfortunately they did it the way that
they did which didn't work that well for
me i think the series will be divisive
with some loving it and others hating it
and whilst i wouldn't put myself in
either camp i think that it could have
been a lot more cowboy bebop has a lot
of potential but what they do with that
potential does remain to be seen i would
like a second season but this first one
gets a six out of ten
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on it whether you agree with me
or not and what you'd like to see next
time we are running a competition right
now and giving away three copies of the
zack snyder dc trilogy on the 30th of
november and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the season
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then a video will be linked
right on screen that's the best for you
i've went on youtube and screen now
click choose the one that's best for the
viewer so go ahead over there right
after this because you'll probably enjoy
it if not thanks for sitting through
this video i mean paul you've been the
best and i'll see you on the next one
take care peace